hey everybody it's Mike frieder here
with on-call compliance Solutions and
I'm back with another compliance tip of
the week this week we're talking about
cmfc control PE dot
l2-3.10.4 maintain audit logs of
physical access yes
[Music]
so hey if you're a defense contractor
who's feeling overwhelmed tired and
alone trying to understand all this cmmc
dfars and nist SB 10171 compliant stuff
on top of an already colossal workload
well I've got great news for you you
found your home here at on-call
compliance Solutions where we can help
you transform into your company's
on-call compliance Hero Let's jump into
it so getting a little more specific now
about the physical security we are now
required to keep actual logs of who came
and went from our facility and then
audit those logs for anomalous Behavior
at least that's what we should be doing
so a few relevant examples here why is
Joe the janitor coming into the office
between 2 A.M and 4 AM every morning and
what is he doing well if nobody's
tracking who comes and goes from the
building we may never know that he's
actually coming and going at those odd
times I mean who knows what Joe could be
up to or why he's always late to work
when he never actually leaves the
building that's weird I haven't been
able to figure that one out myself maybe
if I was watching the access logs we
could actually learn more another
example deals with the auditing of what
is referred to as Tailgaters I know
they're in traffic and they honk at you
all the time and you just want to slam
on the brakes and show them with a real
Tailgater your car looks like not that
kind of Tailgater okay those people who
will fob in and then let their buddy in
right behind him could be an authorized
user could be a non-authorized user no
big deal until cui comes into play and
what's worse is again A lot of times
they may have a friend that came to work
with them for some stupid reason and
then they're just walking right through
the door right if we don't have proper
monitoring on that we really have no no
idea what's going on in our building and
there's certainly no way to go back and
take action on someone that we don't
have monitoring on so what about a
camera system versus a fob only system
well what I'll say is that the uh you
know
on this one uh there's very few areas
where I think we may be able to get into
a into an opinion from an assessor so
the assessment criteria is that we have
to determine if physical access logs are
maintained okay that's pretty easy fob
system takes care of that except that
there is no real way to make sure who
swiped in is who the fob swipe says they
are so yes it should be physical
possession but of course that can be
duplicated or reused If lost kind of
yucky for that reason I really think
that in this case to truly meet the
intent of the control along with Access
Control you should be prepared to back
it up with a camera system caching those
people on camera seeing what's really
going on at the door could you pass an
audit without a camera system in place
it's a great question but the answer is
no already because of a previous control
requiring you to monitor the physical
facility and support infrastructure
let's see what the assessors are looking
for on this one how to answer for the
control
so there's only one thing they're
looking for on this one which is to
determine if audit logs of physical
access are maintained so you're going to
go to your access control system or
you're going to go to whatever your
access log is maybe your visitor log Etc
and you're going to show us the assessor
it's a demonstrate kind of pass-on
control implemented via the visitor
access system all visitors must check in
at the front reception area and complete
a visitor review and sign in form and
agree to all company policies okay
that's how I would I would sort of
answer that control
so hey at on call we work with defense
contractors just like you who have had
all this dfars nist itar and cmmc
compliance stuff dropped into their laps
like a seagull on a sunny day and we
teach you how to level up and be a
proper on-call compliance hero for your
company eliminating gaps gray areas and
getting this solved all while showing
you how to leverage compliance is your
secret weapon to land more Defense work
with higher profit margins now that's
what becoming an on-call compliance hero
can do for you if you're looking for
more help getting compliant guess what
you're in the right place our compliance
experts are always on call for you and
you can visit CMC complianceecrets.com
or check out the bio below for links to
get help right now guys look I had three
phone calls coming to our office
yesterday alone these guys weren't
interested in Services they were calling
us just to get help on the controls I
promise we're always happy to help okay
we know this stuff is confusing we've
been very fortunate to build out a
pretty good sized company doing this
stuff all right we love our defense
contractors and if you're one of them
and you're struggling you're banging
your head against the wall and all you
need is to figure out one control to
just call us all right seriously I'm
here for you uh honestly it's just it's
part of what I consider to be Goodwill
Good Karma you have a great experience
with us maybe you'll refer us to one of
your other defense contractors and
either way we're happy to help seriously
I'm on camera saying that I mean it it's
really what we live for here
uh and again we understand this stuff is
complicated we understand the government
has not made it very easy to figure it
out the Cyber AB hasn't really made it
very easy to figure out uh hey you know
what that's cool I will all right and
we're building solutions to help the
defense industrial base do a better job
of that each and every day to lessen the
burden on you to increase the security
on the country and you know what we just
generally think it's really important so
if you love the content that we're
putting out here for you or you just
love what we're all about help us out
with a big thumbs up on that like button
or even better smash the Subscribe
button to get the latest compliance
content as soon as our compliance nerves
roll it out until the next compliance
tip my friends stay safe and secure out
there thanks for watching we love giving
back to you guys hit us in the comments
below to let us know what you'd like to
know more about when it comes to
information security and compliance and
I'll see you on the next one
[Music]
thank you